and as mentioned at the top biden
said the word crisis nearly a dozen
times tonight but he didn't use that
word to describe what's happening
at our southern border in fact he's
laying out the welcome mat
for the illegals congress needs to pass
legislation this year
to finally secure protection for
dreamers
the young people have only known
america as their home government
protection for
immigrants who are here on temporary
protective status who came from
countries
that set by man-made and natural made
violence
and disasters as well as a pathway to
citizens or farm workers who put food on
our tables
[Applause]
joining me now live from the u.s mexico
border is tom holman
former acting ice director tom is this
the ultimate incentive
for a never-ending flow of miners across
our border
yes he stood on the national stage and
doubled down on his promises
if you don't think the talk of amnesty
and daca has driven these numbers
along with free health care look he he
created this crisis
you and i talked about it before he
knows what great crisis he's been
through before
he knows how to stop him he's done just
the opposite he's filled out our border
security to win an election
to win the progressive left bow he sold
off his country
and this is by design this is what open
borders looks like
tom don't you think this is all
purposeful neglect
i mean if they want if they thought that
covid was truly the crisis
that biden made it out to be tonight at
this point with all the vaccines and
out there and and people have already
been infected and so forth
they would shut this border down
tomorrow if they
really thought it was it but everything
that we're learning about
according to this new york times
reporting today
that covet positive illegals are being
released into our communities by dhs i
mean
we're being told that we're not going to
be able to fly if we don't have a
vaccine
but migrants who have a positive cova
test are transferred to a
shelter operated by the city others
spend a night or two at the
respite center and then board planes or
buses to their destinations around the
united states
so tom americans have to wear masks
outside
while vaccinated still but covet
positive illegals can do whatever the
hell they damn well please
that sounds fair exactly he's not taking
copyright he would have held up title
42.
you know you know title 42 said we kept
people out during the pandemic he
reversed that now he's bringing
children are being released in the
communities along with families with
children under sex
and look it's just not dhs releasing
positive coveted people but
all these million dollar half a billion
dollar centers are building the welcome
centers are building
they're inundated with coping cases so
thousands of colby cases are being
released knowingly in the u.s by the
bible administration
and let's not forget the border patrol
has over a thousand
godaways a day and who knows how many of
these people are infected with covet we
know they're carrying opioids and drugs
we noticed many are m13
many of our single adults are going to
get across the border not get arrested
and claim the banner two years they can
sign up that amnesty promise
joe biden made he is throwing gas on an
open fire and he knows it
well you know it's bad tom when um the
arizona democrat
uh senator mark kelly uh was kind of
calling out biden a little bit tonight
on on the issue of the border saying
he's going to continue to demand
the resources and the enforcement
necessary to fix this problem
because he sees it arizonans do not like
this
texans don't like this and i think when
the rest of the country really sees
what's going on and they're just
beginning to see it they're really not
going to like it
so this is a terrible issue for for
biden which is why i didn't want to talk
about it tonight tom thank you great to
see you